uh well that's that's what i'm trying to
be like yo i got doughnuts
all right if i'm like really like
doughnut clout
i was telling brian uh i was like if i'm
really falling apart i'll eat like three
doughnuts ryan van holtz yeah i was like
i'll eat like three four donuts he's oh
yeah it's a dark place do you love that
guy i love him i think he's a great dude
so we we're working also on a movie with
brian van gaal
separate no he's in
you know who that is
he was in a movie he was on a show
called cougar town
you know um but he he was also in
blackhawk donald he's like a real legend
yeah he's done thousands of movies and
stuff right and this dude comes in with
these [ __ ] degenerates
and he fit right in this yeah
yeah that guy
that dude is a part of our group man
yeah yeah
he used to date courtney cox amanda pete
now he's a lovely wife oh yeah your wife
yeah you met her she's great awesome dog
named chubb yeah awesome dog
this experience doing this movie was
good right i think it was beautiful
is the best one of the best experiences
of your life 100 me too uh
like no cap like no
exaggeration um
i don't know something about it was just
like
the group of people you know what i mean
like even the first day like i had met
theo once he came to a show when we
played i think in in
louisiana is that where he's from yeah
yeah well he he came to a show and i
don't know
uh he knew one of the rappers so he came
through right so i met him there
and then um
and then when i saw him on set he was
like
like i remember you i was like yeah and
then he was like
you got the thangs and he made me
[ __ ] give him give him a vape all
right right thanks hey yeah yeah he
can't let me ask you something about
that guy he can't afford vapes because
all he does is ask for everyone else's
vape but he would have his own
that's what it is
well i realized he was like i need to go
get one and i was like
you do yeah
yeah yeah yeah i do i don't mind yeah
yeah but you do yeah and then you want
to bought one yeah and then he and then
one day he came in with one that was
like zero percent
nicotine
so he's like is it cool if i hit yours
every once in a while to get the kick
i'm like 100 yeah
yeah because i would have like [ __ ] i
i was going to bring my bag in my left
in the car i mean i have like 12 half
like like half dead vapes yeah this
company is cool elf bar yeah that's what
i have yeah it's pretty cool
the flavor flavors are good yeah
wavelength did yeah exactly dude both
guys of course there's only three
companies but yeah
there's like 12. yeah other swamp oh
okay okay yeah yeah yeah it was a real
because i i'll be honest with you i've
done
a lot i think in my career you mean a
lot of
movies and tv shows and stuff and um
i have to say that this one was the most
comfortable yeah just in terms of like
oh i can [ __ ] up
or i can you know i mean um
experiment or i just felt comfortable to
be myself and to do things
and then i just liked you know sometimes
you're in something and you just kind of
look around and go
everyone's nice i wouldn't hang with any
any of these guys but in this show it's
like i could see myself hanging out with
all these guys i said that on the last
day a couple of us were sticking around
and um
i was like i don't want this to be like
like when i go on tour
everyone's like your best friend and
then after it's like other than your
couple homies like you don't tap back in
with them i was like i want us to hang
out like if there's no wrap party like
i'll throw a rat party yeah you know
what i mean like well that's why you're
here you know you mean i want to just
exactly out and go extend my [ __ ]
little dick and go
bring your little dick and then make it
an average yeah connect them well
connected them together you know exactly
so
i just want to say to
shakewell that um
this whole experience was perfect yeah
you think guys this was fun dude you're
a fascinating person you're fascinated
sharing all that thank you fascinating
guy right yeah perfect guest for us you
know i mean like-minded